[Musique]
l'organisation mondiale de la santé tire
la sonnette d'alarmé il devrait bientôt
devenir prédominant au micron est une
grande menace nous avons agi rapidement
pour ralentir sa propagation
mais malgré ces mesures rapides les
données de ces derniers jours ont montré
plus de raison de s'inquiéter omicron se
propage à une vitesse n'ayant jamais été
observé avec les autres variant et le
fait que l'on place le vario omicron
comme étant bénin nous préoccupe la
pression va continuer à s'accentuer
durant les prochaines semaines et nous
devrions dépasser des 3000 patients
atteints du coc vide en réanimation très
rapidement et atteindre les 4000
patients atteints du coc vide en
réanimation autour des fêtes les états
unis le pays le plus endeuillé du monde
par la pandémie se chiffre donc huit
cent mille personnes sont décédées de
suite du coc vite nous avons traversé
des moments très difficiles des moments
d'angoissé aussi et tout
particulièrement cette épidémique je
pense très très peu l'avait anticipé
donc oui c'est normal et je pense je
n'ai plusieurs fois dit mais notre
époque est marquée par une forme de
retour du tragique de l'histoire
j'espère que on n'est pas encore au
temps du rtf j'espère qu'il ya des rats
avec des règles d'équité d'eric d'euros
donc je demande l'application de ces
règles rien de plus rien de moins ce qui
était imposé à nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque doit être aujourd'hui imposé à
emmanuel macron les gars bien sûr on va
s'ennuyer à mourir ce soir devant
l'interview d'emmanuel macro sur tf1 ce
pas moi qui le dis évidemment c'est ce
que dit jean luc mélenchon depuis les
antilles je pense qu'on a déjà demandé
beaucoup on va continuer à avancer avec
au fond les trois piliers de notre
action vacciner vacciner vacciner c'est
le premier pilier personne n'est dupe
emmanuel macron du candidat temps je
suis beau dire que moi les jeux seraient
face à lui je demanderai même parce que
vous êtes candidat à leur dites le nous
dites le nous il est candidat se moquer
des gens se moquaient de la france avoir
à tel point abîmé la république durant
ce quinquennat
on ne peut pas dire que la république et
la démocratie auront été
réparer 61% des électeurs d'emmanuel
macron ont une bonne opinion d'elle
depuis le congrès des républicains la
popularité de la candidate est sur la
pente ascendante de la fébrilité comme
moteur et l'hypocrisie comme carburant
c'est du mauvais macron du méchant
ciotti disent matin un agrément bonne
dans le figaro cette campagne se
transforme en duel en tout cas cette
fébrilité du camp la grogne est une
bonne nouvelle pour nous un président
doit forcément un moment présenté son
bilan ça ne me choque pas du tout ce qui
va surpris c'est qu'il fasse une
émission qui ne soit pas en direct c'est
toujours mieux d'avoir du direct de
l'avis de l'imprévu de la surprise
oubliez pas j'ai été entre guillemets sa
première victime politique puisque
lorsque j'étais garde des sceaux où
j'avais appelé ma fille du prénom de
maman il avait violemment contestées il
avait même dit que j'étais indigne de la
république donc l'arène publique ne
pouvait ne pouvait pas m'accueillir va
cueillir ma fille en raison de son
prénom votre compagne madame knafo
va-t-elle vivre avec vous à l'elysée si
vous êtes élu alors ça je ne réponds pas
des questions personnelles ma vie privée
ne regarde que moi et je trouve vraiment
les français les français sauront le
jour venu une tesla model 3 pulvérisé
encastré dans une camionnette samedi
soir à paris bilan un mort et sept
blessés graves le conducteur est
chauffeur de taxi et il affirme avoir
perdu le contrôle de sa voiture selon
lui la [ __ ] d'accélérateur seraient
restés coincés depuis 2018 l'autorité de
régulation des transports aux etats-unis
a relevé onze accidents plus ou moins
graves qui implique le loto pilotes où
le régulateur de vitesse automatique de
la tesla
est commercialisé ça c'est vraiment
c'est son livre saison